when we're talking about waves
transmission is when a wave passes from
a material into another one for example
here we have the sun
93 million miles away on average and
imagine the different materials that the
light has to travel through from the sun
to say hit
one of these sand particles right over
here think about what it needs to be
transmitted through
well it's going to travel through 93
million miles of the vacuum of space and
that's one of the amazing things about
light waves is that they don't need a
medium they can travel through vacuum
through emptiness but then it's going to
travel through several miles of earth's
atmosphere so it's going to travel
through several miles of earth's
atmosphere it'll hit these the lenses of
these sunglasses it'll actually travel
through the lenses of the sunglass the
sunglass has some width or some depth to
it and then it'll go out onto the other
side and it will hit the sand right over
here
now one thing you might realize is the
amount of transmission and what gets
transmitted is dependent on the
wavelengths of the wave in this case the
wavelengths of light and also about the
material that they are going through so
for example these sunglasses right over
here many sunglasses try to keep out uv
light ultraviolet light which is a
higher frequency than visible light but
that's what causes sunburns and that can
also damage your eyes so those high
frequencies are not making it through
and we could also see that this sunglass
right over here it kind of has an
orangish color which means that things
that are closer to that end of the
spectrum closer to the red the oranges
and the yellows are getting through
which means that it's filtering out blue
light so the blue light isn't getting
transmitted through as much as say the
red orange and yellow light and that's
why we see this as red orange or yellow
and then of course the light will get to
that sand particle
now transmission as i mentioned it isn't
just about light waves we could talk
about one of our other favorite types of
waves for example sound waves if you are
in a room you have probably experienced
the fact that even if you were to close
the door and i do this a lot because i
record a lot of videos this is me in my
little closet recording a video this is
a top view or what i'm doing right now a
lot of times my kids are in other parts
of the house and they're making a lot of
noise and as we've talked about sound
waves are nothing but traveling pressure
waves through the air those air
particles are knocking one into another
but in order to make it to me they need
to get through that wall and the way
they do that is they get transmitted to
through that wall so those air particles
make the particles or make the atoms or
the molecules in the wall start
vibrating they bump into each other and
then the particles on the other side of
the wall will bump into the air in my
little closet and then we will have once
again the sound waves make it to me now
the overall magnitude of the sound the
volume of the sound will likely be
diminished and not all of the
frequencies of the sound will be
transmitted equally different
frequencies of sound waves are better at
traveling through certain materials just
as we talked about with light waves so
now when you look at the world around
you or you hear the world around you or
look at other types of waves just think
about how it's transmitting from one
material into another